[Musik]
und jetzt willkommen waren wir ein video
ja leute ich hoffe euch geht es gut mir
auch so weit
ja wir haben gerade sonntag haben ich
habe mir gedacht dort produzierte mal
ein bisschen vor
morgen geht nicht bei mir die uni wieder
los ein bisschen lernen aber ich habe
lust und ich bin voll motiviert guckt ja
lernen und jagte wahrscheinlich ein
video schon gesehen
wir machen heute einen challenge die
wahl 2013 gefühl total in aber ich habe
hier jetzt schon mit meinem mitbewohner
auf seinem kanal gedreht und ihr habt
gesagt alex das muss auf jeden fall auch
immer auf seinem kanal kommt und jetzt
eigentlich gesagt mir sagte war ein
großer blauer ist für mercury kannst du
wenn wir erst mal den pulli ändern
ja ich und wir haben folgendes gemacht
jeder hat vier bilder herausgesucht
schieben kriegt man nirgendwo
ich habe nicht geschlafen
wir haben jeder vier bilder ausgesucht
von frisuren von youtube youtube hast du
diese leute die so videos mario eick auf
mein zeug so und wir zeigen jetzt
gleicht dem anderen
und der muss dann halt erraten welcher
youtuber das ist voll gut oder die
challenge habe ich mir auf jeden fall
ausgedacht ich bin der erste der das
macht und wenn ihr das kultur die idee
dass auf jeden fall jetzt sofort mein
daumen nach oben oder es machst du einem
jahr am 5 durch wird sagen machen
erstmal stück voranbringt
ich schlucke ich wusste dass wir jetzt
mal eine nochmalige sagt schneider ja du
viel gesagt nee du fängst echt und genau
wir fangen erst damit was etwas
leichtere man was meinste ferien an
diese haben ein bisschen leichter für
den anfang ist eigentlich nicht schwer
wird schon sagen jetzt leicht smm war
meint ehrlich wenn wir zu dumm macht das
einfach scheiße also wartet
hier haben wir immer aber ich habe echt
gedacht vielleicht sagst du auch
abgeraten eine viel kürzere seiten ja
aber sorry mucke das nicht welchem
youtube gehören diese haare
christian ich weiß nicht warum aber ich
habe gerade erst überlegt das weiß nicht
aber dann ist mir sofort ein gefallen
ich wollte eigentlich auch näher
heranzoomen bei daran erkennst du sein
diese ausbeutung ja scheiße und jungen
wenn du noch mehr angst das wäre echt
und für kuba
da werde ich auch so rangehen können
also ich sag mal so wenn du dir jetzt
erregt dann bist du echt gut und zwar
wäre es das würde ich mich auf den arm
nehmen damit das weiß ich warum welche
soll denken das video ist aber es ist
nicht beliebt ist weil es eigentlich gar
nicht erinnern was du nimmst du solltest
denken wir dass essen
ich sage es ist da gehst du 100 prozent
prozent wo anhalt präsent das letzte
antwort nee falsch und zwar ist das sony
vaio kennst du ja ja das würde ich mal
sagen alex steht 1 0 führung
jetzt muss man abwarten welchen youtuber
endlich die challenge meganisi aber die
macht voll spaß und das macht wirklich
richtig spaß erfolg gegen einen echt nix
wissen ja okay so welchem youtube gehört
diese frisur
es ist ein deutscher ja ist in
deutschland gehört die frisur aber der
macht selber youtube ist die
leistungsträger sollten
ich würde sagen das ist der freund von
oder wie auch immer verheiratete oder
wie auch mal von david bis jetzt ja aber
das wäre ja werde das jetzt beweist der
macht ja keine user videos oder jener
nachts ist lena zu müssen ja felix von
alan ist das den letzten märz antwort ja
hascher hug alter das könnt ihr auch
jeder sein oder für mich schauen es war
wohl klar eine doch so so mein lieber
jetzt war vielleicht hin berechnen diese
habe aber vielleicht könnte man das auch
an diesem abend hinter ihm lag es ja das
könnte zu senken hintergrund seien dann
ist das gut wie sicher letzte antworten
ist ziemlich nicht das ist schiri david
mit dieter bohlen jo-jo hintergrund ist
dieter broda nur das waren ich wollte
ein bisschen auf die falsche 8 und
falschen weg braucht welcher youtuber
ist das hier
ich glaube das ist ganz verrückt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ding ist jetzt nämlich juli muss den
nächsten erwarten und ich darf nicht
erwarten sonst habe ich eindeutig das
ding hier für mich entschieden ich habe
jetzt gedacht entweder die so heißt es
sofort oder beweist es nicht kennst du
auf jeden fall obwohl ich weiß habe ich
doch schon was ich weiß nicht ich glaube
schon dass du denn gern sich genommen
hat sich erhalten standard zu den trends
müsste eigentlich hat das noch nicht
gesehen hat jetzt eine million autos
deutschland müsste es dann wenn der
nicht deutsch ist es unfair ich habe
folgende deutsche genommen nein das ist
nicht ungefährlich ist ein geschenk
also ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich
sicher dass länder sagen ich blieb als
richtig die wollte ich sogar ich war
stadt aufbringen kann man leute ich muss
das jetzt einfach erwarten sonst steht
sie wieder unentschieden okay
wem gehört diese frisur des rates ist
ausgleichen ich würde erstmal sagen
minuten
sind graue strähnchen
frau geschrien ja aber was willst du
schon
ich weiß nicht aber jetzt schon kürze
für die noch keine ahnung hatten
ich sage verbluten das ist richtig
ich habe versucht sie die richtige
geschichte auszupacken eltern recht gar
nicht
ich sehe nur manchmal irgendwelchen
trends ohnmacht ja irgendwie wieder
bayern mussten richtig riechen
ich gehe eigentlich seine videos und
seine besucher halt wegen den sack nicht
mal so ich habe den größten gesprächen
gewonnen
so einfach geht das nur mit mir kann man
sicher nicht mal eben anlegen und hätte
immer ein jo ich erwarte man eben wohl
mehr wie die challenge ist natürlich
wieder gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall
mal daumen nach oben da und schaut auch
mal beim juli vorbei da haben wir das
nicht auch schon mal gedreht ich
verlinke euch das netterweise mal
relativ weit oben in der video
beschreibung
wir drehen jetzt nämlich noch ist das
ist so 2016 kommen wie gesagt zehn szene
juli also wir sehen uns morgen wieder
worden konnten mega cooles video und
zwar 50 überraschungseier auspacken
video das wird so geil ich habe nämlich
schon ordentlich eingekauft haut rein